"Thank you for subscribing to Vox. There are
a million of you! This is insane."
"I can't believe there are three million of
you."
"That's like one, two, three.."
"Four million!"
"I can't believe there's eight million of
you out there."
So I want to shout out Tal Leming. He is the
artist behind the typeface that we have used
in literally every single one of our videos,
which is Balto.
I wanted it to feel like a friend who knows
a lot about what they’re talking about because
that’s what typefaces do, you know, they
give the tone to the words.
Ben Marriot’s tutorials are very helpful and
I especially used his paper cutout tutorial
for many of my collage videos. The uterus
that I made.
One internet resource I use a lot for visual
inspiration is designspiration, I hope that's
you say it.
I want to shout out Laurent Dury. He is a
composer on APM. I asked him if he would play
some music for me and he played a little jingle.
When you’re making the music are you ever
thinking about where it’s going to wind
up? No, sometimes I’m feeling when writing,
“oh it could go to that type of documentary
for example but most of the time I’m wrong.”
For a lot of our videos that I've worked on
we use David Rumsey’s map collection. And
it just makes it so easy to see how a region's
borders have been recorded through time.
I'd love to shout out Geolayers and the maker
of Geolayers, which is this incredible software
that we use to animate all our maps. It’s
by far my favorite tool.
Rick Prelinger, who founded the Prelinger
Archives about like 20 years ago.
There was no YouTube in the year 2000 and
it was really hard to see moving images online
and especially hard to see history online.
You can tell that he’s thought about this
stuff for a really long time.
We’ve only begun to scratch the surface
of what we can do with old sounds and images.
A resource I use a ton is Newspapers.com.
It has thousands of newspapers going back
to I think like the 1700s sometimes.
I use factbase a lot. It basically compiles
everything Donald Trump has ever said or tweeted
or written about, and they’re doing the
same for Biden.
I want to shout out the Internet Archive.
You can get really beautiful high-res scans
of books and there’s really no alternative
online to being able to search TV captions.
News programming in particular is required
by law in the United States to have closed
captioning for deaf people and so the transcripts
you're seeing most of the time is the closed
captioning that we’ve pulled out of the
video stream and turned into a searchable
index.
How many servers do you guys have?
Oh my gosh so many.
I'd really like to shout out Connectedpapers.com.
You can type in one topic and it gives you a
specific paper and not just that paper but
other research papers connected to that topic.
Worldradiohistory.com. You go to the website
and it's rough to look at but I have pretty
much used this website in every single music-related
video I've made probably since 2016.
And I wanted to shout out the creators of
After Effects. They’re the people that changed,
you know, movie and tv graphics from being
these million dollar machines to something
you could do on a personal computer.
We were trying to make something where you
could understand the pieces that you're fitting
together so that you can create
anything that you have in your mind.And
we were clearly at the right place at the
right time, we had no idea that there would
be this rolling wave of digital video adoption
that has lasted 30 years now and is still
growing.
There’s a plugin I use for After Effects
called Motion 2. It’s just like a workflow
type plugin where there’s a lot of small
features added into this toolbar.
So AEscripts.com is a library of scripts and
plugins that you can use over in After Effects.
And I think the most useful one is the layer
random shifter script.
I want to shout out the Rights and Licensing
team at Vox Media who keep us from how do
I say this? They keep us from doing things
in our videos that people would not like in
a law related sense hmm.
Yeah making sure that all the elements we
have in the video we are able to use, I think
is probably the best way to put it.
Who on our team gives you the most grief?
Nope. Not gonna do it. Not gonna call out
people, that’s mean!
I want to shout out our amazing field production
crews -- freelancers that we have great relationships
with all over the US and the world.
I want to shout out Priti Gupta, who is a
fixer who's worked with us on several India
videos. It's thanks to people like her that
we get to speak to people on the ground and
understand what's going on at a deeper level.
I’m shouting out the Styles and Standards
team, aka Vox’s copyeditors.
Can you tell me if you can think of any mistakes
that our team makes over and over again?
I mean there are just little things like the
Vox style is not to use periods in US or DC,
which comes up constantly. That’s going
to be my next tattoo I think.
So I want to shout out the Vox newsroom for
doing such an incredible job on Covid coverage
this year. They've just been a really invaluable
source.
I want to shout out all the viewers around
the world who have contributed translations
for our videos.Some of our videos have gotten
upwards of 70 langauge translations. I can't
even name 70 languages off the top of my head,
that is phenomenal.
And I wanted to thank our first subscriber.
Was I first?
Ok technically he’s our earliest remaining
subscriber.
I was coming over to vox from the Polygon
and Verge network of Vox Media so when I heard
there was a mainstream news outlet coming
from the same publisher, I was like yeah,
let me get on board here right away.
Anything that you would like to see us cover
more in future videos?
Reading Vox was always more of a US focused
thing, obviously, so if I had to ask, hey
more Canadian stories, I'd be interested in
that. But that's more of a very light wish.
I guess I have to shout out all the people
who have worked at Vox and have contributed
so so much to us. These people all taught
me so much during the course of my career
here.
I don’t think there’s anything else … except
to just say thank you.
Thank you
From the bottom of our hearts
For your incredible archive
For sticking with us all these years
For building this tool that we use so much.
The sheep noise that happens when you get
an error is Dave C.'s mother. Dave C. is one
of the developers on the team -- he's still
on the team, in fact he's the last one of
the original people who is still directly
on the team and his mother just recorded the
noise with her mouth. Just "Baaa" and that's
the noise. "Baaa"